♪ ♪ ♪
- Maman, je suis aussi grande
que toi! a a a a a a a a a a a é
le plus difficile?
- Dans lns la campagne?
- Depuis cinq semaines, oui?
- Ne pas voir la famille,
par rapport à ça.
- Quand on voit Dominique
Anglade avecprprprprprprprprprùe
ses forces. La cheffe est
nerveuse. Sondeurs et analystes
prédisent la pire débâcle dans
l'histoire du parti libéral
- Chaque campagne, le jour
où ça commence à sortir, puis
chiffres, c'est sûr
que c'est stresst.t.
- La prochaine fois, on devrait
faire ça ensemble.
(rires)
- Après le dîner, la visite
de bureaux d
parce que les nouvelles
sur la sortie du vote sont
inquiétantes.
- Merci. Bye-bye.érérérérérérér,
qui a pratiquement inventé la
recette d'une élection gagnante,
n'est pas au rendez-vous.
- Oui.
- Je dois y alr.r.
- Même dans la circonscripti....
- Combien de transports?
- 15 aujourd'hui. À partir
de 10 h ce matin.
élections depuis presque 30 ans.
Lundi, elle n'avait ee
15 transports d'électeurs
à coordonner. À une autre
en faisaient plus que ça
enen une seule heure.
CLAUDETTE PITRE, présidente,
Asso. libérale St-Henri-Steueues
répondre, les gens, on les
rappel l la veille pour
confirmer le tout, sont pas là,
tout a changé avec la pandémie.
à trouver des bénévoles aussi.
- Il faut continuer à bâtir,
continuer à amener le changement
au sein de notre formation
politique,HeHeHeHeHeHeHeHeHeHeH,
il n'est pas "callé".
Moi, je te dis, j'étais 124e
sur 125 comtés la dernière fois.
- La soirée électorale
libérale, qui préfère regarder
la télé sans lsoson, pour ne pas
entendre les commentaires.
Dominique Anglade sait
entendre ses idées.
- Je pense qui qui qui qui qui .
- Cette électrice n'a pas voté
pour la Libéral parce qu'elle
est souverainiste.
Elle juge que le racisme a joué
SYLVIE VAILLANCOURT
- C'est une fee e intéressante,
qui a des idées et qui a peut-
être un peu de la difficulté
du sexisme, malheureusement,
et je pense que sa couleur
de peau lui a nuit.
- Qu'est ce qui vous fait dire
ça?
- D'après les observations que
j'ai enten2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.2.
- Qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit?
- Euh... bien, "est-tu d'ici,
elle"?
- 20 voix d'avance
sur une boîte.
- Dominique Anglade, d'origine
haïtienne, était la seule femme
et la première persoererererere.
Il n'en a pas été question
rarant la campagne. Pourquoi?
- C'est dur pour moi de répondre
à cette question-là. Je ne sais
ont peur d'aborder le sujet?
- Donc est-ce que c'étaiunun
handicap d'être une femme noire
dans cette campagne?asasasasasa-
là. Ce n'est pas le terme que
j'utisiserais.
- C'est un défi  ?
- Je pense que c'est un défi,
c'est sûr. Être une femme
dans un milieu d'hommes,
être une femme noire dans un
milieu d'hommes où la majorité
est blanchlélélélélélélélélélél.
Il n'y a pas de doutes.
- Allô François?
- Dominique, oui?
- Félicitations pour
- L'autre défi, immense,
qui attend lpopoliticienne,
c'est de rebâtir des ponts avec
les francophones. À l'exception
les Libéraux n'ont plus aucun
députés dans les régions
et leur base militante
semble s'être volatilisée.r r rs
au temps, il y a un élément
dea a qui est vrai là dedans.
Mais le Parti libéral
a des racines profondes.
été de son temps. Quand c'était
le temps de donner le droidede
vote aux femmes, on l'a fait.
Quand c'était le temps de parler
de lfait. Quand c'était le temps
de parler d'hydroélectricité,
on était toujours de son temps.
Quand c'est le temps de parler
de la lutte aux changements
- Tu es élue Dominique.
- Finalement, Dominique Anglade
a défié les ononostics.
- Le message, ce soir, il est
assez clair. Les Québécois
du Québec, nous demandent,
d'être l'opposition officielle
à Québec.
(applaudissement